so I took the documentaries and so
that's all I watch horror movies and
documentaries but the horror movies are
such [__] now that I'm switching to
Western they are so bad they're so bad I
love horror and they're so [__] bad
I've been trying to watch them I can
tell you a couple to watch the only ones
speak no evil yeah like that Watcher
that was good see what was the one where
the girl was in the woods
she was deaf
I love that you love hard you gotta come
to the heart we have a horror group that
watch horror movies every Tuesday night
but we're so
I don't know we were so upset now that
last night we said [__] this Rotten
Tomatoes gives it 99 all the reviews and
we watch it and we're like this is a
piece of [__] it's all the same now so
Kevin in the woods it's so everybody all
I want to do is I hate horror movies
where you know
um uh it's quite obvious you need to get
out of the [__] house and you don't
Joey I don't get it yeah you know it's
like when I'm in the old days where it's
like you know you know what was the
thing about when they in the 70s and 80s
you didn't have like again we go back to
the cell phones and technology so people
just couldn't pick up their phone and
call the cops they couldn't do whatever
so if you're out in the woods or you're
out we're out well they try to recreate
that now they're doing it works
sometimes my Signal's not working
oh I'm so bad they're gonna figure
something else